what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with the conclusion of Adam the
legend of blue Marvel and I can almost
guarantee I'm enjoying my vacation so uh
yeah so I will be back I think Wednesday
Tuesday or Wednesday of next week is
when I get back it's kind of weird
talking to you guys it's almost like I'm
talking to you while I'm on vacation but
I will be on vacation so I'm recording
these beforehand but nonetheless right
so in this video what we basically cover
here is the ending of it all right the
conclusion of the whole thing which is
great the way this is done because what
you end up doing here is you initially
pick up with really Adam Brashear
showing up with the rest of the
superheroes and just being like okay so
there's only really one option that we
have which is to effectively disperse
his energy right me just kind of
absorbing it and then dispersing Connor
Sims across basically all existence but
the the fear that the superheroes have
is that in doing that what it's going to
do is it's going to let off such a large
amount of antimatter energy that it'll
actually rip open the fissure between
the antimatter universe and the positive
Mana Universe to such a degree that
it'll basically destroy the world and so
they're actually resistant to Adam
Brashear doing this so much so that when
Adam Brashear says either you can help
me willingly or you can just stand by
and do nothing but either way I'm gonna
do this when he races off the mighty
Avengers go after him and they actually
end up fighting Adam Brashear in an
effort to stop him now this is kind of
Adam brashear's experience going
toe-to-toe with these guys and and their
own experience right in the sense that
Adam Bashir sees them as getting in his
way and kind of a reminder of the way
things went back when he stepped down at
the request of Kennedy right Kennedy
said you got to step down you got to
walk away
um you know it's for the betterment of
everybody and in this instance the
Avengers are saying no no you gotta step
down you gotta walk away it's for the
veteran of everybody you can't engage in
this but in the mind of Adam Brashear he
knew then much like he knows now that
he's right that he has to keep he has to
stay the course he has to fight the
fight so when the Avengers show up here
and they face off against him understand
it's not one of these like super
lopsided battles that Kevin Grievous
gives us here instead like the mighty
Avengers hold their own kind of I guess
like they're able to hold their own to
would agree but the reality is that Adam
Brashear is able to overcome all of them
right like Simon Williams uh Wonder Man
he's able to overcome Aries he's able to
overcome this Century so with the
exception of the Incredible Hulk these
are some of the strongest superheroes on
the entirety of the Avengers roster and
Adam Brashear is taking all Commerce now
there does come a point when Adam
Brashear when the blue Marvel fights the
Sentry and the fight between the two of
them is pretty intense but it's also
incredibly fast I remember the century
is like uh he's like a Superman analog
honestly Hyperion is closer to Superman
than the century is but the centuries no
slouch right this guy was able to go
toe-to-toe with World breaker Hulk he's
ridiculously powerful and they're
trading blows just back and forth and
back and forth and so there's literally
a point when the century like once he
kind of knocks Adam Brashear to the
ground he's like Stand Down uh I'm
starting to get ticked off and in
response Adam Brashear knocks him into
the atmosphere like literally punches
him into orbit with one hit that's how
powerful Adam Brashear is now one of the
other things I also want you to notice
here he hasn't really hardly taken any
damage from anybody right like he has a
cut right he has a little bit of blood
that was drawn by the century but that
was it but even then he was powerful
enough to punch the Sentry into orbit
it's like somebody's showing up and and
knocking Superman into orbit in one
punch that's what this is it's just a
crazy level of power that Adam Brashear
has and so ultimately because he's
exhausted himself so heavily even in his
fight with the Sentry when Robert
Reynolds comes back he can barely stand
Adam or sheer can barely stand so
seemingly at the moment the two of them
are pretty equal in power and in fact
Adam Brashear basically passes out and
so that point they get him back to the
Baxter building as a form of recovery
but also kind of to hold him in place
right to keep him there so he can't
necessarily get out and try to engage in
this scheme again and so what Susan
storm had done was actually go and grab
Adam's wife and brought her here for no
other reason than the fact that like his
wife needs to be here now the other part
of this is his wife can bring a line of
logic and reason that none of the
Avengers can do right because it's
really more of a gentler hand in a
discussion that needs to be be hat
because Adam Brashear isn't simply just
fighting for the the purpose of like
trying to defeat Connor Sims there's a
lot that he's holding in and a lot of
the anger that he Harbors towards his
wife is actually anger he Harbors
towards himself now while the two of
them are talking of course the Avengers
themselves end up having to leave the
Baxter building and travel out into New
York because Connor Sims has finally
immersed and with all these anti-matter
storms that are erupting all over the
place they're basically destroying
things that are out there people are
dying and so for the Avengers it's as
much cleanup Duty as it is using what
weapons and you know ideas they've come
up with but they all fall short in
comparison to the idea of Adam Brashear
his suggestion as risky as it is is
really the only one that can save the
day so where he initially breaks out
right he literally escapes his his
confinement tube uh for his healing
process he ends up seeing his wife and
where he initially turns a blind eye to
her or really just kind of turns us back
to her response is enough right like
I've had enough of this you and I are
married which means that no matter how
bad things get we talk right that's the
deal that we made it's the bargain we
made do things get bad do things get
hard yeah but we talk we keep it going
that's just the way that it goes it's
the agreement that we struck so you're
not going to turn your back on me Adam
breshear and you're not going to walk
away you're going to talk to me because
I know you but despite how you may think
about how our whole marriage started and
all that kind of stuff I know you and
what I know is you're not really mad at
me you're angry at yourself I mean sure
you're kind of pissed off because of how
everything started but like the last you
know 30 years or 20 years or however
long it is that we've been together at
the end of the day it was the best
decision we shared some amazing times
and those far outweigh any of the bad
times and certainly this that we've
endured as a couple you're mad at
yourself because President Kennedy asked
you to step down and you said yes you're
mad at yourself because you could have
been a hero out there and you could have
been making the world a better place but
you didn't you basically stood hidden
away under this this using this idea of
well things might get worse if I make
myself known as basically a shield for
you to maintain what was by all
standards a measurement your own
cowardice nobody put a gun to your head
nobody told you that you couldn't come
back and it became quite clear after a
while with all these different
superheroes running around and all the
stories you were reading in the X-Men
and the Avengers and all that kind of
stuff you could have stepped into the
role of being a superhero and everything
would have been fun you could have come
back at any point in time but you chose
not to right like at the end of the day
you want to blame me for the decisions
that you made and how you feel about
those decisions but it's not my fault
it's your fault Adam Brashear so either
nut up and accept that or just wallow in
cowardice but whatever it is you need to
be something better than this and you
need to get out there and you need to
you need to prove that you're right you
need to tell them that you're right and
if they won't listen to you make them
listen to you and that's exactly what
happens and that's exactly what he
needed because what it does is it
creates reconciliation that this is the
woman he married and this is the woman
he loves and so ultimately they actually
put their problems to the side right
like Adam Brashear forgives her for what
it was that was done and then in turn
she's like you know I love you and he's
like you know I love you too and it's
like you know we'll get this sorted when
everything's all all said and done but
right now baby I gotta get out there
into the City and I gotta whoop some ass
so he ends up flying out
right ends up taking off out there and
Connor Sims again is just kind of amping
up in power and so ultimately Adam
Brashear confronts him now what he does
here and this is what's really kind of
cool he ends up creating what's
basically a cyclotron now when it comes
to physics I don't know what that is I
knew what it was when I was younger but
I'm old now right I forget stuff you
know my old age I'm 38 years old right
this memory is not what it used to be
you know the thing behind this they said
he basically wants to create a system
whereby the entire molecular structure
of Connor Sims can be destabilized more
than it already is right now right so in
effect if we're talking about Connor
Sims being a Jenga set there's already a
few pieces missing it's teetering a
little bit but not quite on the verge of
falling over what Adam Brashear wants to
do using a combination of the different
powers of the mighty Avengers all
operating in a way that he has outlined
is to in effect start removing pieces
from that Jenga set and then once enough
pieces are removed he can deliver the
killing blow and knock it over ideally
you don't knock over the Jenga set but
for the sake of the sake of this event
ample that's our goal is to knock her
with a Jenga set and I guess to lose the
game I don't know
but the point is this that in all of
them working together in an effort to
disperse the energies of Connor Sims it
actually doesn't work and there's a
couple reasons why the first is because
Connor Sims is a lot more powerful than
he was when he and Adam Brashear had
previously fought his anti-matter energy
has been continuously growing the other
reason is because with this huge amount
of power Adam Brashear simply can't
siphon off enough of it and destabilize
him in the way that he needs to be
destabilized and so as a result of that
it takes a couple shots to try to get it
down but before Adam Bashir can get to
that second landing and to try to siphon
off into the power of Connor Sims yet
again ultimately Connor Sims ends up
just letting off this massive amount of
energy and when he does he ends up
killing Candace he kills the wife of
Adam Brashear which removes his ability
to reconcile with her or at least it
seemingly does I can't of course have a
life together but it's one of those
things where all that pain and all of
Anguish gets set aside because in that
moment there right then when she's
passing on he knows more than anything
that he loves her and that's really what
it takes when it comes to that kind of a
situation right when it comes to like
the ending of relationships marriages
friendships what have you it's only
either when they're not there or when
you're forced to accept the fact that
they won't be there that you come to
terms with realizing exactly how much
you loved or cared about that person in
the first place and so what this does is
it leads to Adam Brashear putting all
that stuff to the side but of course
once Candice effectively passes on and
she essentially dies that now it's just
Adam Brashear and his Connor sips the
truth about this is that it's the final
battle here nobody else could have
stepped in and offered any real measure
of a conflict here right any real
measure of a fight The Avengers couldn't
handle this the Fantastic Four couldn't
handle this it really just is an Adam
Brashear Connor Sims fight and initially
it starts off as a kind of knock down
drag out battle between the two just a
straight up fist fight and where Adam
Brashear says like I tried to see things
your way I try to take your approach but
at the end of the day I can't do that
right I can't force Humanity to change
and kill everybody who disagrees I can't
bring myself to do that that if humanity
is going to change and evolve then
Humanity has to do it of its own
volition and if in the process humanity
is incapable of doing that and It
ultimately destroys itself then that's
just the way things go it's the choice
of the human race right the the you know
where I would argue as a person right me
Rob Jefferson I would argue of what use
is freedom to a society that would use
that freedom to destroy itself the
response of of Adam Brashear here would
be because that's their choice it's the
choice that Humanity engages in those
who could do something don't do anything
meaning that those who are doing
something whatever it is they want to
have done that's what gets done right as
the fight goes on between the two of
them in the end Connor Sims gets so
exhausted from the battle that they
endure because he's just expending so
much energy he can't hold his own
against Adam Brashear anymore and as he
starts to weaken Adam Brashear at that
point having worn him down then
basically starts absorbing his energy
literally absorbing the entire essence
of Conor Sims and when that happens
Connor Sims is destroyed but the last
thing that Adam Brashear says to him
instead of doing this in a place of hate
he simply says goodbye Connor I don't
don't hate you I pity you and what
you've done I forgive you he says I pity
you and whatever you've done I forgive
you Connor Sim so he does it from a
place of love as opposed to a place of
death and so following this you pick up
about a week later after all this is all
said and done of course Tony Stark
invites Adam Brashear to become a member
of The Avengers he actually doesn't do
that and in fact um Adam Brashear would
not become a member of The Avengers
until the second run of Mighty Avengers
when Luke Cage was leading the team
instead you don't really hear much about
Adam Brashear after this now I will
create an Adam Brashear playlist for
those of you guys who really like the
character of blue Marvel I will create a
playlist that'll have like all the
subsequent appearances he does have a
major role in Al Ewing's ultimate that's
really where his character just shined
after this story was an alien's
ultimates and it made sense because
after this story Al Ewing wrote The
Mighty Avengers run that blew Marvel's
in and then it made sense that he would
also write the uh the ultimates run that
features Adam Brashear as well but
that's the story of Adam Bashir guys
right his his wife you know before she
died and basically fashioned him a new
costume because she believed that he
would eventually want to become a hero
one day but at the end of the day he
basically kind of gets back out in the
world and goes back to being a hero so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end again I love
Adam the legend of Lou Marvel an
absolutely phenomenal story again I
think it's the greatest superhero origin
story in the history of Marvel Comics
but let me know what you guys think in
the in the comment section thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later
peace